as a teenager my next guest suffered a
slew of mental health issues crippling
anxiety depression ADHD and autism
at 15 she had a manic episode Landing
her in the hospital well that's where
she says after just one meeting a
psychiatrist coerced her into saying
that she was transgender
now she had questioned her gender
identity at the time but now she says
that she really started exploring it
soon after Soren eldaco was at a support
group where she met a nurse practitioner
who says she says prescribes
testosterone upon request after only a
30-minute meeting she got her first
prescription for cross-sex hormones
including at an outrageously large
off-label dosage of testosterone Soren
at the time was just 17. so fast forward
to age 19. after a brief phone call and
a quick visit to a clinic she went under
the knife getting a double mastectomy
but the surgery was botched leaving her
disfigured and in severe pain she's now
21 and suing all of the health care
providers who preyed upon her as a teen
she joins us now exclusively Soren
aldaco along with her attorney Ron
Miller Soren thank you very much for
having the courage to share your story
with us now two weeks after the double
mastectomy I know you were back at the
hospital what happened
so um I ended up going back to the
hospital after reaching out to the
clinic initially with my concerns I
chose to go to the hospital in Dallas
because they had someone who had
experienced the type of surgery I
underwent and when I showed up to the
hospital I mean they took me seriously
which was a huge contrast to the way
that my original surgeons treated me
when I showed up there I
but I showed up there I was put my my
incisions were reopened with only local
anesthesia and I was there all night
so Lauren after that did the clinic
offer you any sort of compensation that
is a horrific uh I mean I can't believe
you went through this any compensation
yeah well we um we did talk afterwards
by email and after I was persistent and
you know very insistently letting them
know that I wanted some sort of recourse
the CEO reached out to me and offered to
reimburse me for the ER visit with the
stipulation that I sign a
non-disparagement agreement which I of
course uh did not I told them you know I
asked them what have you done to make
sure that this doesn't happen to any
other person have you spoken to your
nurses have you uh do you plan on doing
any sort of training and at that point
they ghosted me
and what did they offer you like a
couple hundred bucks or yeah basically
to sign your to sign a waiver that you
wouldn't sue them probably now Ron given
Soren's um psychological uh condition at
the time that this was all happening
how do you legally view what these
medical professionals did to her
well Laura um it's just a matter of
gross malpractice um this is a situation
where Soren experiencing these
significant uh mental health issues
autism uh really just looking for a
place to fit in amongst her peers goes
to uh the internet and finds some stuff
about becoming transgender she reaches
out to a medical practitioner expecting
competent and unbiased advice and
instead gets put on a fast track to
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
and then as you just discussed a botched
double mastectomy that has left her
permanently disfigured for the rest of
her life
Soren what do you say tonight to young
people who may feel you know upset in
their lives confused uh who are in this
same situation and and feel pressured to
go undergo this type of procedure
surgery hormone blockers what do you say
to young people tonight
ask the important questions you're not
compromising your integrity or betraying
Yourself by thinking critically about
what's happened to you by unpacking why
you feel the way you feel instead of
just accepting it at face value
and Soren how are you doing now like
right now how are you doing
I'm a little bit nervous
I wanna
thank you well it's like I I want to
change the world I mean I think a lot of
people feel that way but I want to make
sure that you know
um this conversation is spoken about and
talked about compassionately because I
really do think that a bunch of people
are hurting and the way we're handling
it right now is just not appropriate and
you know I like to describe myself as a
student of Life Friend of the world and
I mean that so you know when I come on
air to talk to you I really want you
know I joked earlier for everybody to
kind of kumbayon not fight so much
um over something that really should be
nonpartisan well Soren and Ron um thank
you these are in many cases these are
children they're not even as old as
Soren was uh and they they need care and
concern Soren and Ron will be following
your case thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else